if i could find
the 60s costume surely i'd be able to
find the 80s and 90s costume that
replaced it well it took me nine years
to have somebody find me that actually
had this costume this one has been
replaced by the poo costume that's being
used in the parks today and so i don't
know of too many of these that even
exist any longer and so that's why i'm
sure it took me so long to actually find
him um and so
why this one is so special is i actually
played winnie the pooh in our local
sears store back in the 90s and just
absolutely had a blast as much as i
loved the 60s one this one was really
very sentimental because i actually
played winnie the pooh